[Music]
from one hater hater to another hater
hater
from one
[ __ ] hater to a hater hater to
another one
anthony trying to uh whatever he didn't
know by the way
oh my god
it's just because we've been saying
[ __ ] haters i timed this one good
by the way title of this video he posted
it opie posted it kumia and his
gaslighting
you know what's you know what's so
stupid about this like
i get [ __ ] for being
the only one no it was me and erock we
were the only two that who also doesn't
like you anymore went to steve c's
funeral and well yeah if you killed the
guy you should at least show the respect
to show up i mean i you know yeah even
in hood people do that jesus christ
manhattan showed up to the [ __ ]
funerals come on and i got it alex
showed up to the comedian's funeral
spin that because he didn't think enough
of steve c to
to pay his last respects uh to the guy
and now he's gonna spin it and try to
make it like it's a bad thing that i i
went there
and the fact is uh oh god don't get me
going
don't get him going
don't do a youtube show then opie i
don't know what to tell you should get
him going
anthony forced me to do all this garbage
all this behind the scenes [ __ ] i didn't
fire first of all it's steve c i didn't
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold
on anthony forced you
this is a new story this is a new one
this one i haven't heard i know a lot of
this lore anthony this is a new one
anthony who wanted steve segon
i could tell you anthony wanted to teach
look i
could be on record as being probably the
guy that hates anthony coomie more than
anyone
as far as this show or anything like i
personally just don't like anthony
coomera
anthony had something to do with steve
sealy no no no no no anthony anthony
wouldn't have given a [ __ ] whether or
not steve c but it's i knew for a fact
opie that you wanted to save money and
you also didn't want steve around
anymore
and you anthony probably just went all
right well do what you got to do man but
like
i'm sure anthony was not the one to go
oh we got to get rid of steve sees
bothering me i know plenty of people
that involved in this situation
personally firsthand involved and i can
tell you for a fact
anthony was not the person that wanted
steve c gone
deep c the company was moving on from
steve c
okay but see when you have no choice the
big opiate anthony brand didn't have a
choice of their own producer that's
[ __ ] i don't buy that i am sorry
yeah that is [ __ ] [ __ ] opie and you
[ __ ] know it it's not like steve c
was making [ __ ] crazy money boku box
he was making good money but he wasn't
making like right like he wasn't making
the kind of money where
anybody in the company is gonna look at
it and go oh jesus why are we paying
this guy so much money exactly it would
have been he didn't have a braun
strowman contract no so it could have
been one of those where they said look
you should probably get rid let's say
they said look we're trying to cut costs
you got to get rid of one of your
producers whatever or well you
specifically got to get rid of this guy
steve sees whatever you go absolutely
not he's part of the [ __ ] show we're
not gonna do that and then you have a
standoff for like three days and
eventually they'll back down right
that's how that could have went right
[ __ ]
i hate him
and i got you know i had to do a lot of
that tough garbage behind the scenes
because you know anthony didn't want to
deal with any of that anthony doesn't
want to deal with anything
because i don't know what the problem is
they're coming in and i'm funny i'm like
yeah but it's the opinion anthony show
there's so much other [ __ ] we have to do
i was having a good morning
but you have a whole you got a whole
staff hope
so if you're having a good morning
on this
i was gonna say beautiful beach but on
this average why would you go
[ __ ] haters
that are gonna show up
why do it
why ruin your day
i would have to do all these stupid
meetings and i know they were a wasted
time but when you talk when you're uh
dealing with executives in a big
corporations this is the crap you have
to do so yeah like going behind the
scenes and complaining and everybody
that worked for you to hr you had to do
that how was that anthony's fault
because when you did that anthony wasn't
there anymore jesus
opster oops
to sit there at a waste of a
of a time meeting or go to lunch with
these people just to stroke their stupid
egos and anthony was nowhere to be found
for just about all of them
our agent would fly in from la he'd be
waiting outside the studio i have new
kids at home i want to just anthony's
defense i wouldn't want to be around
this [ __ ] either let's be honest
he is he is just god damn he's
insufferable worse do you think do you
think that he's streaming now because
his wife now is totally checked out
mentally
like she probably doesn't even talk to
him half the day now because again like
i said
maybe i i i think that also
he
[Music]
opie will never admit this but opie
misses
being
somebody
opie misses being
somebody who people would go like oh
yeah i know that guy opie opened anthony
you're not that anymore and i think he's
trying
to find some of that but at this point
it's dead it's not like when he goes
live on youtube it's like 40 people
watching him i think but then also all
he does is piss and moan
and i want to be clear i'm not cheating
on people that do youtube shows and get
40 views because we started there we
were 40 views at one point and that's
what happened
but also we weren't we didn't have a
serious xm contract we weren't on camera
we're going to make three million a year
right even even bubba the love sponge
who obviously was not as big as opie and
anthony was
even when he went to the internet he was
doing better you know so
of course there's a nice thing between
starting at [ __ ] zero and passing
through 40 and going from thousands of
listeners onto sydney millions millions
yeah man how can you not pull 100 people
you should you should be pulling some of
those people in look i do not like
howard stern but if howard stern were to
go what happened
he's jewish look just consider this you
i haven't heard i haven't heard any
howard stern update since 1998.
is he doing good oh you're oh you are
sitting down okay so here's the thing
oh it's a long one
right he used to hate ellen and make fun
of her is he still irreverent is he
still fighting the system all the time
what does this have you heard of the
show called x factor
have you ever heard of agoraphobia wow
that was really great that's all he does
he's the paul abdul of that show exactly
no because at least paul abdul's kind of
hot
um
they have the same wig guy though
[ __ ]
but
if howard stern were to when he's done
with serious he's like i'm done and
retiring and he were to go i'm going to
do like one show a week on youtube
he would still pull pretty good numbers
and i don't like him and whatever but he
would pull still because it's howard
scott absolutely opie isn't that you
know
those days are gone
one excuse after another and there i am
sitting with my agent in some dumb
restaurant having breakfast in the
middle of manhattan when i want to be
home with my family because someone had
to do that
yeah but i have a feeling that you're a
control freak and you would rather do it
because you didn't you would rather be
the one that's in charge yeah and you
guys probably had some sort of like a
pretty good idea of what you both wanted
and what you were gonna expect and then
yeah like be like do we both have to go
to this
opie is absolutely that [ __ ]
that'll be the control freak and do take
control of everything in the [ __ ] you
know in the world and then [ __ ] blame
you for him having to do so much work
yeah
the nerve
the [ __ ] nerve
you don't want to do any of that stuff
behind the scenes so don't spin that
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
hundreds and hundreds of hours behind
the scenes that i had to deal with
hundreds
when i wanted to be with my young family
oh
what i come in i'm just funny it's me
i'm like yeah good but it's opie and
anthony
you have to do all this other garbage
ah he's honestly he is the [ __ ] worst
he clipped this himself and put it up on
his own channel to get some views
he is dying is he dying guys
i totally believe that he did every
single little thing at the uh at the xm
show considering how professional his
current streaming setup is i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a prediction just to show you
how far he's fallen
i'm gonna have taperclip this segment
okay
i bet you that us talking about this on
our not our main channel on our clip
channel will get more views than his
video
do it i'm going to let's do
it the challenge is laid hope is just
garbage
has never taken responsibility for
anything
garbage how do you spin it me and erock
we
it was uh i don't even remember what day
it was on i think it was the weekend
we traveled pretty [ __ ] far we drove
together yeah you guys still friends
yeah you guys you guys who's you rock
worker for though and right
right
i thought he was like your protege yeah
when he like you guys at one point what
happened
because we told you i get the impression
you mistreated them probably
a bit too [ __ ] 100 and it's like
and there were some things they did to
erock on the air that were funny like
some bits that were bits yeah but then
it was just [ __ ] where it was like all
right it's just all the time now we're
just [ __ ] with this guy
i'll be honest he robs erock's my good
friend like irl uh he's he's one of the
nicest guys a very loyal dude and to get
somebody like erock to be like bro i'm
gonna go work for aunt now [ __ ] you dude
you're a piece of [ __ ] in my opinion i'm
not speaking for him i'm just saying my
opinion
thing
to give our our respects our our uh to
steve c who you know worked really hard
on the opium anthony show and then also
was a friend to a lot of us
and no one else from the show could be
bothered by that and then the guy's
gonna turn around to spin that [ __ ] go
aft yourself yeah it's nice that you
showed up when he was dead why didn't
you fight for him when he was working
for you
yeah that steve c thing to this day i
mean knowing
knowing in retrospect
how many [ __ ] uh
people he went around and snaked
it it's kind of hard not to
think that you snaked cfc because he was
doing it to every every time there was a
problem you just go up the court real
hots it's this guy's fault it's that
guy's fault come on opie man stop it